всім добрий день дорогі друзі Як ви
знаєте тисячі партійців європейського
солідарності сьогодні воюють на фронті і
серед них наш добрий друг наш дорогий
колега Сергій шакун голова нашого
луганського осередку зараз він в силах
тероборони звільняє нашу землю від
російського окупанта ми зустрілися
сьогодні на Донеччині Сергію дуже
сумуємо за луганщиною хочеться як не
швидше там побувати А які настрої на
Луганщині після цих
псевдо-референдуму не дуже наша купована
Ну то що люди звонять і просять щоб
бистріше швидше звільняли тому що
луганчани пам'ятають 14-й рік теж
Сватово теж звільнення северодонецьким
січанськ з Рубіжне коли перший раз
познайомились так що і люди хотять уже
щоб відновилося Луга українська влада на
Луганщині і насправді
по що в розвиток той який ми робили
робили командою
Та ж сама нова дошкивка Та ж сама
Попасна попаснянщина
Северодонецьк так що треба звільняти
Україну від цієї нечисті від
Московського загарбника москалів кляті
робити їх Полонне брати і все буде гарно
все буде Україна Ми дуже сумуємо і за
новатошківкою і за Попасною і за всіма
северодонецьком лисичанському сватовом
сама другими нашими серцю столиця
дуже-дуже сумуємо і мріємо як не хоче
дійсно туди повернутися приїхати
потиснути руки в ким мужнім людям які
сьогодні тримаються в окупації що можна
сказати про безпеку ситуації сьогодні на
Донеччині на Луганщині настрій наших
збройних сил наших сил теоборони
дивіться настрій Приходьте тому що ми
розуміємо що може одною ногою на
Луганщині ми біля криміною Там біля
сватого і
то що ворог скажені Скали зуби і
кидає знову і знову людей це м'ясо це
частково в цих мобілізованих і
таке враження що вони сюди
чи об'їдені чимось то що лізуть не
міняємо
нічого в них не вийде тому що це наша
земля це наша Україна і ми будемо
звільняти крок за кроком і впевнений що
в найближчий час даже не дивлячись на те
що ця паскуда перекидає ракетами
обстрілює не дає спокою нам
все буде Україна наша партія настільки
дружна що Черкаські партійки вони
плетуть сітки які розходяться як гарячі
пиріжки Це дуже добре що дівчата в
Черкасах є нікуди не виїхали тому що
луганщина Донеччина Майже без дівчат
дуже погано добре що всі повиїжджали що
вони не заважають Так що я дівчата Дякую
вам від луганчан в луганських партійців
європейської солідарності за такі
подарунки То що хочу кажуть що більш
зима Скоро треба зараз в лісах ще
ховатися
вже просять білі сітки тому що на жаль
ворог його луплять але але ми звільняти
до зими до білих мух треба звільняти
Україну
було Менше плисти Білорусії ми власне
щось сьогодні потрібно на фронті
звичайно бачите Сергій просить в першу
чергу зброю але треба і буржуйки треба й
генератори треба імбирці треба зимова
форма ну це це Ми потихеньку нашим
дорогим друзям колегам які сьогодні на
передові на нулі які наші найкращі
дуже вас любимо вам ми пишаюся це
Калинівська громада Київської області
передають ляльки оберіги мотанки
листівки малюнки такі різні бачиш діти
роблять такі машинки
і такі еко-торбинки
ми живемо
з перемогою і дуже вдячні тому насправді
як оберіги тому що коли привозиш хлопцям
Да Он уже Бежать хотять взять да Бачиш
так що я не оберіг то що насправді
хлопці це таке розбирають і все
нормально воно дуже потрібно на фронт
треба приїжджати не з порожніми руками
от зараз генератори дуже потрібні тому
що зима буде непроста а нашим хлопцям
має бути тепло світло Світло і таке інше
несуть не суть
ми приїхали так само Подякувати І
обійняти побачити і оцінити ситуацію і
безпеку тому що важливо що Працюючи на
міжнародних майданчиках говорити з
нашими партнерами Що відбувається на не
тільки на тимчасово окупованих
територіях І що відбувається на фронті і
просити стільки зброї для того щоб Ціна
була наших хлопців мінімальна втрати
дитині для того щоб постачання зброї
було постійною і якомога більше бо
звільняючи якнайшвидше наслідок
тимчасово окупованій території ми
розуміємо що менше буде тих воєнних
злочинів які росіяни творять на нашій
землі тому ми сьогодні єдиний як ніколи
Україна об'єднана навколо однієї мети
Перемоги і вклоняємося до землі в
кожному вояку які сьогодні воює всім
волонтером які допомагають армії всім
цим але ще пункти такі шипун який ну
ніколи не дозволить щоби не за ним було
останнє слово Давай кажи
виїжджаєш звідси з таким списком чи не
вистачає їм треба броню а втору зброю
військову форму автобус
треба треба над цим будемо працювати
друзі дійсно маємо все робити для того
щоб наша армія отримала якомога більше
зброї і це вже наша робота на
міжнародному фронті це буде Україна
друзі Слава Україні